Dear Fellow Scholars, we have some delightful news!
Elon Musk and Sam Altman founded a non-profit
artificial intelligence research company that
they call OpenAI. The funders have committed
over one billion dollars for this cause. Their
goal is to make progress towards superintelligence,
leveraging their non-profit nature to make
sure that such a breakthrough will be done
in a controlled and beneficial way.
As of the current state of things, most of
the bigger companies with strong AI groups
publish their work regularly, but as we get
closer to Artificial General Intelligence
and superintelligence, it is a question how
much they will share.
We have talked already about how enormously
powerful a superintelligence could become,
and how important it is to make sure that
it is developed in a safe way, make sure to
check that video out, a link is in the description
box. It is really mind blowing.
So everything they create will be open, therefore
the first question that came to my mind - is
really good that anyone will be able to create
an AI? What about users who are interested
in using it in a way that is harmful and dangerous
to others? This was subject to a lot of debate,
and one of the conclusions is that at the
same time, most people are sensible, and they
expect that the number of friendly AIs will
overpower the bad guys. We don't know if it's
the best case scenario, but it is definitely
better than the case of one company owning
the only superintelligence.
At OpenAI, they already have researchers of
their own, and their research projects will
be completely open. This is amazing, because
it rarely happens with companies as they usually
want to retain the intellectual property of
their projects.
Amazon web services are also donating a huge
amount of resources for the company.
The fact that just like at research institutions,
the researchers can publicly share their work
may be a big deciding factor when recruiting,
which is, according to the founders, already
going really well.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!